[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazing
donde les presentamos la actualidad del
continente africano Mi nombre es amalven
offman comenzamos con los titulares una
nueva crisis migratoria en el continente
africano este año entre enero y marzo
4677 migrantes expulsados por Argelia
acabaron en la ciudad de ataca en el
desierto del norte de níger Allí están
abandonados a su suerte privados de
Refugio atención sanitaria y protección
una situación sin precedentes según
médicos Sin fronteras
Ruanda conmemora el genocidio de 1994
que marcó para siempre la historia del
país en el discurso inaugural de la
ceremonia el presidente polkagamé afirmó
que la mentalidad genocida seguía
vigente en la región como Según él en el
este del país vecino República
democrática del Congo la administración
del presidente Joe biden está haciendo
todo lo posible para establecerse como
socio prioritario en el continente
africano y contrarrestar la presencia de
China analizamos la guerra de
influencias entre Beijing y Washington
en África
abrimos esta edición en la región del
zagel al sur del desierto del Sahara
cada semana cientos de migrantes
rechazados por Argelia acaban en asamaca
el primer pueblo al otro lado de la
frontera con níger el centro de tránsito
gestionado por la organización
internacional para las migraciones esta
desbordado por la afluencia y solo acoge
a un tercio de las miles de personas
expulsadas veamos
son médicos estudiantes comerciantes
pero en este centro de tránsito para
migrantes les une una misma condición su
desesperación
cada semana cientos de migrantes
rechazados por Argelia llegan a samaka
el primer pueblo de níger al otro lado
de la frontera ya son más de 4.500
personas las que deambulan aquí
es como hablo estoy temblando lo
entiendes estoy pasando por una
situación traumática siento dolor dentro
de mi cráneo ahora mismo porque no hay
buena comida no vivo sano ni pescado ni
carne nada para la gente la gente está
sufriendo mucho Aquí la situación es muy
difícil y muy dolorosa son malienses
guineanos marfileños congoleños que tras
kilómetros de caminata por el desierto
desde Argelia descubren el centro de
tránsito gestionado por la organización
internacional para las migraciones en
asamaca los depósitos de agua están
vacíos la comida es insuficiente los
refugios escasos y la temperatura
alcanza los 48 grados centígrados
durante el día despojados de todas sus
pertenencias en Argelia según sus
testimonios lo repatriados no pueden
llamar a sus familiares ni pagar el
viaje de vuelta condenados a sobrevivir
en esta prisión de arena por un tiempo
indefinido los militares y la policía de
Argelia nos dijeron que la organización
internacional para las migraciones aquí
en níger nos enviaría a casa llegué aquí
el 11 de enero ya han pasado tres meses
se lo digo yo tres meses cuando llegamos
aquí
según médicos Sin fronteras es una
situación sin precedentes que desborda a
los 1500 habitantes de asamaca
ha llegado a un punto en el que se ven
obligados a robar a la población los
animales de la población para
sacrificarlos y alimentarse no es porque
sean ladrones pero cuando tu estómago
tiene hambre no puedes hacer nada más
tienes que buscar comida
para las asociaciones de ayuda
humanitaria la organización
internacional para las migraciones juega
un papel clave en el engranaje de la
política de externalización de fronteras
que lleva a cabo la Unión Europea en
suelo africano en la región existe el
sentimiento generalizado de que la Unión
Europea tiene su parte de
responsabilidad en esta situación
cambiamos de tema en Ruanda la
conmemoración 29 del genocidio de 1994
contra los tutcia comenzado entre abril
y Julio de 1994 casi un millón de
personas fueron más sagradas el
presidente ruandés polkagamé pronunció
un discurso para marcar el inicio de los
100 días de conmemoración en el
mandatario explicó que la ideología
genocida sigue presente en la región y
evocó la situación de crisis en el este
de República democrática del Congo
marianne nos informa es incendiando La
Flama del recuerdo que el presidente
marcó el inicio de los 100 días de
conmemoración del genocidio de los Tutti
y Ruanda tras los testimonios de dos
supervivientes como es habitual el
presidente Paul kagame hablando a los
numerosos diplomáticos occidentales
presentes recordando la inacción de la
comunidad internacional durante esta
masacre por cagame también expresó su
preocupación por las ideologías
genocidas que según él sigue siendo
presentes en la región
y Bruno de facto Sin embargo no podemos
ignorar el hecho de que persisten cosas
como la violencia y la incitación al
odio no tan lejos de aquí
en este estrato el presidente irlandece
se refiere sin citar a la situación de
los benevolencia en el este de la
República democrática del Congo
efectivamente desde la reaparición del
grupo armado en 23 hace más de un año la
discriminación y la violencia contra
esta población estas poblaciones
congoleñas calificadas irlandeses
oritutti por los extremistas congoleños
no han hecho más que aumentar en algunas
regiones del país como recordatorio el
gobierno congoleño y la otros países
como Estados Unidos acusan a Ruanda y
apoyar a los Rebeldes del en 23
pasamos ahora a otro tema Estados Unidos
quiere recuperar el tiempo perdido en
África para contrarrestar la importante
presencia de china en la región la
administración biden está aumentando el
número de visitas de altos funcionarios
a un continente olvidado Y despreciado
por la presidencia de Donald Trump
estas imágenes muestran el final de la
gira africana de kamala Harris se ve a
la vicepresidenta de Estados Unidos
saliendo del usaca la capital de zambia
a lo largo de su viaje que también la
llevó a ghana y tanzania Harris no dejó
de elogiar la creatividad del continente
al tiempo que pedía una nueva era en las
relaciones
la administración biden Harris y el
pueblo estadounidense están dispuestos a
asociarse con ustedes para acelerar la
innovación y el espíritu empresarial que
ya está en marcha fijémonos en lo que
está ocurriendo en el Continente en
tecnología ciencia agricultura y
energías limpias por ejemplo donde la
innovación está resolviendo problemas
locales y cuestiones globales
pero detrás de estas fórmulas
entusiastas se encuentra un plan
geoestratégico que forma parte de una
competencia entre Estados Unidos y china
con África como uno de los campos de
batalla en el Continente Beijing lleva
ventaja y la vicepresidenta pudo
comprobarlo en zambia donde las empresas
chinas han construido carreteras puentes
terminales estadios etc
en dos décadas el comercio de china con
África se ha multiplicado casi por 30
ahora es cuatro veces mayor que el de
Estados Unidos con los países africanos
china ha conseguido así asegurar su
acceso a los recursos estratégicos de
los que África está ricamente dotada
petróleo en gabón o Angola bauxita en
Guinea cobre en zambia uranio en namibia
y cada vez más cobalto y litio materias
primas cruciales para la transición
energética y el desarrollo de coches
eléctricos tras el fin de la era Trump
que no se interesó por el continente
africano la administración biden se
afana por recuperar el tiempo perdido
desde principios de año cuatro
funcionarios ya han sido enviados al
continente la embajadora de Estados
Unidos ante las Naciones Unidas linda
Thomas Greenfield la secretaria del
tesoro Janeth y Allen la primera dama
Gil biden y del secretario de estado
Anthony blinken el presidente Joe biden
ha insinuado que podría ser el siguiente
en la lista sin embargo no hay garantías
de que los países del continente vayan a
preferir ahora a Estados Unidos sobre
todo porque muchos africanos encuentran
en Beijing el único que ha visto en
África una tierra de oportunidades
cuando occidente sólo la ha considerado
en términos de guerras y pobreza
terminamos nuestro recorrido de
actualidad africana en togo en este
pequeño país de África occidental
situado en el Golfo de Guinea los cursos
de literatura en la escuela y el colegio
se basan incluso desde la independencia
en el estudio de autores franceses y de
algunos clásicos africanos pero hoy el
mundo literario tuvo las lucha para que
los jóvenes conozcan los autores locales
y puedan apropiarse nuevamente de su
identidad cultural
esta biblioteca móvil se desplaza a las
zonas más remotas de los suburbios de la
capital togolesa Lumen desde hace cuatro
años se instalan lugares donde el acceso
a los libros es difícil y donde los
agentes culturales están ausentes como
aquí en México soy feliz porque mis
padres no tienen suficiente dinero para
comprarme libros gracias a esta
asociación los jóvenes pueden leer y
escuchar cuentos durante el fin de
semana o durante las vacaciones
escolares el objetivo es inculcarles el
gusto por la lectura a través de libros
que cuentan la historia de su mundo
africano en francés
hoy la lengua de aprendizaje en nuestra
zona es el francés es a través de esta
lengua que damos a conocer nuestra
historia
para reencontrarse con su cultura es
necesario ir más lejos según el escritor
togolés
él es uno de los que han desempolvado la
literatura en las escuelas hasta 2020
junto a los clásicos franceses la
mayoría de los libros estudiados eran
obras africanas relacionadas con la
descolonización y la independencia
los clásicos africanos se estudiaban en
las escuelas pero hoy antes de
identificarnos con África debemos
identificarnos con nuestro propio país
es importante partir de la literatura
togolesa
de la literatura desde ahora se dará
prioridad a las obras togolesas
contemporáneas antes que la literatura
tan africa y mundial
construir Si queremos construir una
élite que de prioridad a su país es
importante que esto se aplique al ámbito
de la educación
en este taller para niños el artista
panafricanista elonbins educa y enseña a
través de sesiones de cuentos según él
la escuela moderna debe combinarse con
una educación tradicional que se perdió
durante la colonización
creo que debemos descolonizar la
educación soy de los que piensan que hay
que enseñar de otra manera que hay que
revisar toda la arquitectura de la
escuela Gracias a este tipo de talleres
hemos descubierto que los niños se
sienten más cómodos expresándose en las
lenguas locales
la educación basada en la primera lengua
o lengua materna debe empezar en la
primera infancia recomienda la UNESCO
pero en togo todavía no hay libros de
texto en lenguas nacionales como lée o
el capie
[Música]
así termina esta edición de África 7
días Gracias por acompañarnos la
actualidad internacional continúa en
trans24